with all the billions of people in the
world it's amazing to think that we're
all different when we're born each of us
grows according to a unique set of
instructions that are inside every cell
in our body all living things are made
of cells they're like small packets of
life inside each cell is a nucleus where
the instructions are stored this
instruction manual is called DNA and
contains all the information needed to
make you you with billions of letters
making up each person's manual of
instructions our DNA is huge and it's
coiled up to fit inside every cell in
our body but how does DNA actually work
on its own it can't have an effect
because it's just the instructions cells
are like tiny factories that follow
instructions in the DNA to create
proteins the building blocks of every
part of our body to create a protein
first the instructions have to be
identified in the DNA and the nucleus
almost like a highlighter pen on
typewritten text then this instruction
is commonly in other words transcribed
into a message called messenger RNA that
leaves the nucleus this message is then
translated to the language required to
make the protein
it's rather like IKEA in the factory are
the golden instructions to enable all
the different furniture to be assembled
this is the DNA if you're getting a
table then just those instructions are
copied and inserted in the packaging
with the panels and screws this is the
messenger RNA then you must assemble the
table according to those instructions
like a factory making the proteins
proteins don't last long typically a
couple of days or even less so they need
to be constantly produced to keep your
body healthy proteins have many jobs in
your cells they carry the information to
make your brain stomach muscle all of
you three important functions of
proteins are building tissues and
muscles protein helps to make you
stronger
digesting your food to help you produce
energy and strengthening the immune
system to fight off infections so your
DNA is there inside you it's working all
through your life to keep you healthy
and making you become the special
individual that you are along with
everyone else and every other living
thing on our world in many ways we're
all very similar to arms to legs hair
and so on and yet we're all different
even in the largest crowd we can
recognize our family and friends just by
how they look when you think of the
population of the world the potential
for variation is huge and it's all
achieved with DNA
you